[Music]
a woman has been found dead weeks after
she first went missing thank you for
joining us tonight at 11 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez police announcing
just today that
35 year old tiffany booth was found in
indian springs
after she and her boyfriend 38-year-old
eduardo clemente disappeared at the end
of september
now authorities are searching for
clemente as a suspect in her death
sasha lofta spoke with tiffany's family
tonight she joins us now to share their
message
denise and brian tiffany's family is
obviously devastated
and outraged they say now they just need
to know what happened to her
that's why they're asking anyone who
might know anything
to step up and speak out we're just
heartbroken
we're just why shock and sorrow
consumed the hearts of those who knew
and loved
tiffany booth tiffany was the kindest
most gentle
soul you would ever meet the 35 year old
went missing in late september
detectives discovered her body weeks
later in indian springs on october 19th
she was just one of those people that
was always
always there for everyone all the time
no matter what and that's why this is so
hard
tiffany's cousins says she and her
boyfriend eduardo clemente took a trip
out of town
but failed to return a few days later
her car was also abandoned
in the ely desert why would somebody
want to hurt her
it just doesn't make any sense police
are now searching for the 38 year old
who is considered a suspect in her death
our whole world is rocked
and we just want to know why we just
want to know what happened as her family
deals with this
unexpected grief they're asking clemente
to come
forward it's just anger just getting
angrier and angrier and angrier
so they can truly honor this beautiful
life
taken far too soon we will never stop
until we find out what happened
and why now if you have seen clemente or
know where he may be
please call metro police or crime
stoppers to stay anonymous
tiffany's family has also started a
gofundme to help with funeral expenses
we have a link to that on our website
8newsnow.com